اولا ينبغي ان
نوجه شكر الى خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ملك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وصاحب سمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس الوزراء
حقيقه كان هناك
ضيافه رائعه
تنظيم رائع
ونتائج
يعني بالغه الاهميه
اهم شيء في كل هذا الزخم اللي احنا شفناه
النهارده او اللي شاهدناه النهارده هو
التفاهم العربي الصيني على ثلاث وثائق
رئيسيه
ثلاث وثائق رئيسيه اعلان الرياض وده
اعلان سياسي يتضمن الرؤى المشتركه بين
الجانبين
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
مقدمه هذه القضايا القضيه الفلسطينيه
وقضايا كثيره اخرى في اعلان الرياض ولكن
ايضا كان هناك وثيقه الخطوط العريضه لخطه
التعاون الشامل بين جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
والدول العربيه وهي تتضمن اوجه التعاون
العمل بين الجانبين في مختلف المجالات
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والثقافيه واي شيء تفكر فيه اي شيء تفكر
فيه هتلاقيها موجوده في هذه الوثيقه
وبعدين الوثيقه الثالثه
الاخيره تعليق الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
العربيه الصينيه من اجل السلام والتنميه
وهي وثيقه تؤكد على الارتقاء بالتعاون بين
الجانبين العربي والصيني الى افاق ارحب
على المستوى الثنائي ومستوى ومنتدى
التعاون العربي الصيني
الامل ان نستمر في هذا الايقاع في تنفيذ
ومتابعه هذه الوثائق وان يستمر المنتدى
يعقد بالتبادل بين الصين
والدول العربيه سواء على المستوى الوزاري
او على مستوى القمه
تامين عامله الجامعه العربيه
اتصور ان هناك حاليا
20 مجال
تعقد الاجتماعات بشكل دوري
وبما يكشف عن
علاقه متطوره
يعني هناك منتديات عربيه مع الكثير من
الاطراف الدوليه هناك الاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك امريكا اللاتينيه هناك
الهند هناك همم روسيا هناك اليابان ولكن
المنتدى الصيني العربي همم تقدم همم تقدم
الحقيقه
بالغ التطور فهو ده اللي انا احب بس شكرا
جزيلا عليكم
التعبير عن جزيل شكرا لما قمتم به شخصيا
وفريقكم في الامانه من حسن تنظيم وترتيب
وهمم
اعداد لهذه القمه العربيه الصينيه فلكم
الشكر والان همم
شكرا سمو الوزير وشكرا مع الامين العام
جميع الدول العربيه واسعد الله مساكم
جميعا وارحب فيكم في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
في اختتام هذا اليوم الطويل وهذه القمم
الكثيره التي اعتطرتها الرياض والتي تعكس
المكانه الاقليميه والدوليه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وهذا الحشد
الكبير والذي وجد اليوم فرصه لطرح كثير من
الموضوعات وتبادل راحه ولا مجمل في
القضايا والعلي في هذه العجال اعرج على
اهم ما صدر عن
المجلس الاعلى
الخليج العربيه في دورته الثالث والاربعين
حيث
رحب المجلس الاعلى باعتزام المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على تقديم المرحله
الثانيه من رؤيه خادم الحرمين الشريفين
لتعزيز العمل الخليجي المشترك المرحله
الاولى قدمت وتم اقرارها في 2016 الان
المرحله الثانيه ان شاء الله
ستقدم وهي استكمال
الرؤيا في مرحله الاولى والتي بلا شك تحرك
كثير من الملفات المتعلقه في التكامل
الخليجي في المجالات الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه كما اعتمد المقام المجلس الاعلى
قانون او نظام التنظيم الصناعي الموحد
لدول مجلس التعاون والقانون الموحد للنقل
البري الدولي بين الدول من التعاون وقانون
اداره الموارد الوراثيه النباتيه النقديه
والزراعه الموحد لدول من التعاون وكذلك
مباركه اطلاق مبادره مصانع المستقبل كما
اعتمد الاطار العام الخطه الاستراتيجيه
للتعاون الاعلامي المشاركه دول الخليج و
ميثاق المحافظه على التراث العمراني
والاطار العام الاستراتيجيه الخليجيه
للسياحه 20 23 20 30 جمله من القوانين
التي اقرها وباركها مقام المجلس الاعلى
اليوم التي كلها تتمحور في تحقيق بعض
مساعدات رؤيه خادم الحرمين الشريفين في
المرحله الاولى والتي بلا شيء اكتسع الى
تحقيق التكامل همم الخليجي في مجاله
الاوسام اكد المجلس الاعلى على اهميه
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر وبتاكيد دعم
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء وهي مساهمه كبيره
من دول مجلس همم
بالمبادرات التي اطلقتها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
لدعم وتعزيز الجهود الدوليه في
مواجهه تحديات التغير المناخي
طبعا البيان نشير ووزع وطبعا كثير من
الموضوعات بس حبيت اعرج على اهم ما ورد
فيها في ما يتعلق في بيان قمه الرياضيه
الصينيه
للتعاون والتنميه والتي جاءت كاول قمه
خليجيه صينيه تعكس هذا هذه العلاقات
التاريخيه الكبيره بين دول مجلس التعاون
والصين كون الصين هو شريك التجاري الاول
لدول مجلس التعاون رقم تجاره البينيه
وتبادل تجاري بين دول مجلس التعاون
وجمهوريه الصين في العام 20 21 بلا 220
مليار دولار امريكي هناك رقبه همم كبيره
من الجانبين نحو دفع هذه التعاون الى
مجالات ارحب كان هناك تاكيد على اهميه
تعزيز التعاون هذا انعكس في خطه
عمل المشاركه الفتى القادم 20 23 20 27
والتي تناولت 15 مجال من مجالات التعاون
المشترك بين دول مجلس التعاون والصين
الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد هناك اهتمام كبير
في دفع هذه العلاقات مع الصين هناك رغبه
فيه استكمال مفاوضات تجاره الحره مع
جمهوريه الصين وهناك همم مجالات كثيره تم
تطرق لها في خطه العمل المشتركه التي وقرت
اليوم والتي سنعمل ان شاء الله على متابعه
الفرق العمل كلهم في اختصاصات لتحقيق
المامون هذه الخطه شكرا
جزيلا عليك واا ايضا انتهز هذه الفرصه
اللي شكرا عليكم وفريق العمل في الامانه
لكل ما قدمتوه لترتيب هذه قمهتين
كما اريد ان هذه الفرصه همم لتقديم همم
شكر خاص لمعاليكم لما قدمتوه خلال مسيرتكم
امين العام من مجلس التعاون اا وكنتم
حقيقه امينا همم بمعنى الكلمه وقدمتم
الكثير وهمم بدونك كذا او ملل
لتعزيز مسيره العمل الخليجي المشترك فشكرا
جزيلا لكم معاليكم شكرا
نعطي المايك لقناه القاهره الاخباريه في
الصف الاول هنا اذا ممكن توقفي
امل الحناوي قناه القاهره الاخباريه سؤالي
ليه معالي وزير الخارجيه السعودي كيف يمكن
للتعاون العربي الصيني ان يقدم اسهاما في
حل عدد من الازمات الدوليه الرهينه والتي
اصبحت تعاني منها الشعوب العالم اجمع في
مقدمتها ازمات الغذاء الطاقه
استراتيجيه مع الصين الكثير يتسائل عن
طبيعه هذه الشراكه وما هي مكاسب المملكه
منها سؤالي ايضا الثاني الامين العام
لمجلس التعاون الخليجي كيف يساهم التقارب
مع الصين في دعم امن واستقرار منطقه
الخليج العربي همم ايضا سؤال اخير ليه
معي الامين العام السيد احمد ابو الغيط
تحدثت عن القضيه الفلسطينيه هناك تصعيد
ميداني في الضفه من جانب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هناك ايضا حكومه يمنيه يجري
تشكيلها برئاسه نتنياهو العمل المطلوب من
المجتمع الدولي للحيلوله دون تفجير
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شكرا
بين مجموعه بوزن وثقل
وحجم المجموعه الدول العربيه جامعه الدول
العربيه
والصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم من
شانها ان يساهم في معالجه كثير من
التحديات التحديات تخصنا او تحديات في
العالم ولا انا في العالم العربي بحكم
اننا جميع الدول الناميه همم اهتمام كبير
وتركيز عالي باهتمامات العالم
والصين كذلك لها اهتمام بهذا الجانب
والتعاون بيننا واستكشاف فرص التنسيق
معالجه هذه التحديات همم بجمع مواردنا
وليس فقط حقيقه مع الصين يعني انه شاهد
الجامعه العربيه الدول العربيه تحرس على
مد اليد للجميع والتعامل مع الجميع لكن لا
شك ان التعامل مع الصين بحجمها وثيقه
اليها مهم للغايه وسيساعد همم في معالجه
هذه التحديات بالنسبه همم الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه السعوديه الصينيه همم مهمه
للرعايه
الصين هي الاقتصاد الثاني في العالم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الاقتصاد الخامس
عشر في العالم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اقتصادها هذه السنه هو الاقتصاد الاسرع
عموما في العالم ويتوقع ان يكون اسرع نموا
في جي 20 همم لبضعه سنوات همم
توفيق الله وبحمده نتوقع ان نصل الى ارقام
ممتازه قويه في النمو الاقتصادي لهذه
السنه وهذا يعجعل الفرص المتاحه للطرفين
من خلال هذه الشركه الاستراتيجيه كبرى همم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بموقعها
الاستراتيجي همم المتوسط بين الغرب والشرق
تطيح
للصير لجمهوريه الصين الفرصه همم
لبناء الجسور همم بين همم
الجانبين الكوكب وايضا بالاستفاده من
القدرات اللوجستيه الكبرى التي تبنا في ظل
رعايه 2030 كبرى الموجود عندنا في نفس
الوقت الاقتصاد الصيني بالنسبه لنا هو اهم
سوق همم
التجاري الاول بالنسبه لمكعب السعوديه
وتعزيز هذه الشراكه والبحث عن تطويرها الى
همم افق اوسع من مجرد تبادل التجاري
التقليدي بالتعاون التقني وبنقل التقنيات
وبمم الاستثمار المتجه الاتجاهين كل هذا
سيعزز من فرص همم النمو للبلدين ويعطينا
همم الفرصه الاستشاك ليس فقط ما ينفعنا
ولكن ينفع منطقتين همم عليكم
شكرا سمو الامير
لا اتصور انه مساله الادانه
وادانه التصرفات الاسرائيليه اليوم اصبحت
كافيه
وبالتالي
المطلوب
عده محاور للعمل
فيما يتعلق
بالجمعيه العامه في الامم المتحده يجب ان
احنا
نتحرك وبسرعه امام الجمعيه العامه مطالب
بالعضويه الكامله
لفلسطين في ادويه الامم المتحده لانه
لا يكفي للمجتمع الدولي انه يؤيد
الفلسطيني فقط
دائما موجوده في
الامم المتحده مطلب المطلب الاخر اتصور
انه مهم جدا الاسراع بالحصول على الراي
لاستشاري من محكمه العدل الدوليه فيما
يتعلق به وضعيه
التواجد الاسرائيلي على الارض
الفلسطينيين يقولون انه احتلال ويجب ان
ينتهي وبالتالي على محكمه العدل الدوليه
عن دور رايها وراي باسرع وقت ممكن الحاجه
الثالثه انه يجب ان انه من يؤيد اسرائيل
او يزعم انه يتفهم المواقف الاسرائيليه
انه
يحذر الجانب الاسرائيلي او هذه الحكومه
عند تشكيلها لانه المعروف انه رئيس
الحكومه المرشح طلب 14 يوما اضافيه
للاستمرار في السعي لتشكيل هذه الحكومه
تحذير الحكومه من اصدقائها امر مطلوب جدا
تصدي المجتمع الدولي لاي افعال اسرائيليه
امر مطلوب جدا
وحده العمل الفلسطيني يجب انه يسرع
الفلسطينيين بتوحيد همم مواقفهم ولا
يسمحوا بانه انه اسرائيل تستغل هذا
الانقسام في الزعم انه ما فيش شريك عربي
استمعنا اليوم ليه
الرئيس ابو مازن يقول ان لا يوجد شريك
اسرائيلي هو فعلا لا يوجد شركه اسرائيلي
لانه لا يرغب في همم المطلوب حركه وحركه
سريعه وحركه مستمره ومطلوب من هؤلاء الذين
يتحدثون عما يسمى القيم
القيم
انهم يساوي في موقفهم من كل هذه القيم
بمعنى
عدم جواز احتلال الاراضي بالقوه لا يمكن
ان يطبق فيه
فضاء او مساحه من الارض ولا يطبق في مساحه
اخرى وهكذا شكرا شكرا
كيف يساهم التقارب مع الصين في دعم امن
واستقرار منطقه الخليج العربي انا اؤكد في
هذه الجزئيه بان مجلس التعاون منذ انشائه
كان دائما حريص على ان يكون ركيزا الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه امن واستقرار منطقه
الخليج مهم جدا لامن واستقرار العالم
وبالتالي التواصل مع الصين هو امتداد
لتواصل همم تم كثير من دول العالم وكثير
من المجموعات في دول العالم من يلاحق
ويتابع الحراك الكبير الذي شاهد عواصم دول
مجلس التعاون في الفتره الاخيره كثير من
رؤساء الدول كثير من رؤساء الحكومات رؤساء
منظمات رؤساء هيئات وزراء قاده فعاليات
كبيره تعقد في هذه المنطقه همم مبادرات
نوعيه تطلق من هذه المنطقه كلها تهدف الى
تقريبا وجهه نظر اثنين ان يكون العالم
مدرك لاهميه العمل جماعي لتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار وهذا هو ما قدمه مجلس التعاون
وهذا ما هو يؤمن به مجلس التعاون دائما هو
شريك في تعزيز الامن والاستقرار هو شريك
في التنميه وبالتالي وجود الرئيس الصيني
اليوم في هذا الاجتماع المهم في هذا
التوقيت المهم هو يعكس المكان التي تحققت
لله الحمد لمنظومه مجلس التعاون كشريك
موثوق في الساحه الدوليه وايضا شريك همم
يتمتع باصداقيه عاليه ويسعى الى تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار وفي نفس الوقت يدفع في
جهود التنميه المستدامه لتعلم الفائده على
الجميع
السؤال الثاني وكاله شين خوى للانباء
شكرا
والسلام عليكم
ما رايكم ففي رايكم ما هي الحوافذ الجديده
التي ستجادمها هذه هذه القمه بين الصين
والدولي العربيه الاخرى لتعزيز العلاقات
والتعاوني بين سينا ودوري العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لكم
شكرا جزيلا ويمكن العنوان الرئيسي
والتعاون والتنميه للقيمتين الخليجيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه وكان هناك تركيز
كبير على ان يكون هناك مخرجات نوعيه تدعم
هذه المسيره وكان هناك مخرجات تركز على
المجال التنميه الاقتصاديه والتبادل
التجاري رفع مستوى التبادل اتجاري لكن
ايضا همم في مجالات التعليم وفي مجالات
الثقافه وفي مجالات شتت همم
لتعزيز التعامل والتنسيق بين همم مجموعتين
مجموعه الخليج العربي ومجموعه العربيه
الاوسا
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه وهذه المجموعتين
بحكم حجمهما همم وفي المقابله الصين
بحجمها همم توليد وتعزيز التعامل بينهما
هذا ممكن لكل الطرفين يعطينا فرص لتعزيز
همم امكانياتنا لاستغلالها بشكل همم اقوى
همم وايضا استكشاف مزيد من الفرص لا ادري
اذا كان همم
لو تسمح لي سمو الامير
موسيقى الخطوط العريضه لخطه التعاون
الشامل بين الدول العربيه وجمهوريه الصين
اللي
يقراها وانا قعدت اقراها لفتره طويله
يشوف كثافه
النشاط القادم
وبشكل ممكن يتوه يعني المجال السياسي اه
مفهوم لكن امسك بقى المجالات الاخرى
الاقتصاد والتجاره والاستثمار والمال
تفعيل الكامل الاقتصاديه
زياده الاستثمارات المباشره تعزيز التعاون
الثنائي والمتعدد الاطراف في اثار نظام
التجاره المتعدد مواصلات تعزيز التعاون في
الطاقه الانتاج في التجاره بس امسك
الملكيه الفكريه مواصلات تعزيز التعاون في
مجالات الاعتراف الوطنيه
يعني
المياه الاقتصاد الرقمي والابتكار في
الفضاء تعميق التعاون في اطار التجاره
الالكترونيه الطفيله الكامل
حاجه
كثيفه جدا جدا جدا
السياحه البيئه والمناخ
اللي يشوف في تعميق الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
يلاقي محاور اخرى في الوثيقه
الثانيه وبالتالي
امدادات
الطاقه والممرات البحريه اهميه الحفاظ على
الامن المائي للدول العربيه
شيء كثيف للغايه يعني حقيقه
يسري هذه العلاقه
نعطي المايك لقناه الشرق
الوزير الخارجيه سمو الوزيره اعلنت
السعوديه عن شراكه استراتيجيه شامله مع مع
الصين هل يجب علينا اعتبار ان ذلك كما
تشير بعض التقارير على حساب العلاقه
التاريخيه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وكيف يمكن المواهمه في العلاقه بين قطبين
متنافسين مثل البكين واشنطن همم اخر اذا
سمحتي شغل البيت الابيض اليوم اي وساطه
السعوديه اماراتيه بشان الافراج عن
المحتجزه الامريكيه في روسيا هل من تعليق
شكرا سمو الامير
شكرا في البدايه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لا تتعامل
بمسارات الواحده نحنا نؤمن بحجم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كاحد دول مجموعه ال20
والاقتصاد الخامس عشر في العالم واقتصاد
نامي بسرعه اننا لابد من كل متفتحين على
التعاون مع الجميع ولا شك ان التعامل مع
الاقتصاد الثاني في العالم اساس ضروري
الاستمرار مسيره التنميه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لكن هذا لا يعني ان انا
نسعى للتعاون مع الاقتصاد الاول في العالم
ولا يعني اننا ننسى التعاون مع كافه
الاقتصادات الكبرى وغيرها في العالم
التعاون متعدد الاطراف والتعاون مع
الاطراف العديده هو
ما سوف ينقلنا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لكن ينقل العالم كله الى مرحله
جديده من النبوه ومن الرفاهيه ولا نستطيع
ان نبني هذا النمو هذا الرفاهيه باستبعاد
فرص من طرف او اخر فلابد نكون منفتحين على
التعاون مع الجميع وهذه فلسفه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انه نتعاون مع الجميع
لتحقيق المصالح المشتركه
الاستراتيجيه السعوديه الصينيه لها عوامل
مهمه ومواعده وتدعم مسيره التنميه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتدعم كذلك همم
التنميه في الصين وفي المنطقه وكذلك عندنا
شراكه استراتيجيه قائمه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كما عندنا شراكه
استراتيجيه قائمه مع الهند همم مع اليابان
مع فرنسا مع بريطانيا مع المانيا كل هذه
الشراكه يعني رسميه عندنا شركات
استراتيجيه همم ولجان تتابع العمل مع كل
هذه الدول لماذا لان الاقتصاد السعودي في
على التوسع كبير ونحتاج كل هذه الشراكات
ونحتاج كل هذا التعاون لنستطيع ان نحقق
مستهلافاتنا في نفس الوقت نطمح ان همم
نستطيع الاستفاده من هذا الانفتاح على
كافه الاطراف في دعم مسيره التنميه ليس
فقط في المملكه لكن في جوارنا وفي منطقتنا
وفي العالم لانه نحن نرى ان التنافس جيد
لكن الدخول في الاستقطاب سلبي للغايه سلبي
للغايه ليس فقط للطرفين التي تقول في هذا
الاستقطاب لكن سلبي للاقتصاد العالمي
للسلم والامن العام لذلك ندعو دائما الى
استكشاف فرص التعاون وفرص همم اذا كان
لابد ما تنافس التنافس شريف لكن لا نؤمن
ابدا بالاستقطاب او الاختيار بين طرفين
واخر همم بالنسبه همم للوساطه همم يعني كل
لا استطيع اقول ان مطلع على جهود
والعهد في الوساطه قد ايه نجحها في مرحله
السابقه همم في العمليه المعروفه اللي
تخرج عن 10 ومطلع على جهود سموه الشخصيه
فيما يتعلق همم
بلاعبه السله الاخيره هذه وانخراطي همم
وتدخل الشخصي همم لتيسير همم هذا الافراج
اما ما يقول الاخرون فلا استطيع ان اعلق
عليه
همم شكرا جزيلا
لاقي سؤال حول القضيه التي تداولها
الولايات المتحده قد تحدثت
انواع التعاون مع الصين سوف تضع سقفا على
تعاون الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
واعتقده اليوم باننا كنا قد سمعنا اعلان
حول الرياضه في ما يتعلق
بالجيل الشبكه الخامسه والدفاع
واستخدام الطاقه النوويه السلميه هل ترون
همم جاكت شوي
مختلفه في مستقبل علاقتكم مع الولايات
المتحده والصين
وسؤال سريع الرئيس الصيني المحلي اليوم
الى مساله الدفع بتعزيز التجاره النفط
وكنانات في الفتره الماضيه هل هذه المساله
قد تنظر في مساله من النظري المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للتجاره النفط مقابل
العمله الصينيه
وكنت كما ذكرت في اجابه السابقه ان نركز
على التعاون مع كافه الاطراف
والمنافسه هي امر حسن فنحن في سوق
التنافسي وعلى بدلنا ان ننافسك كمملكه مع
مجموعه من الاقتصادات وولدين
استراتيجيه
ترتكز على رؤيه
2030 وهذا سوف يدفعنا لنكون اقتصادا
متنافسنا
لنتعاون مع اكبر عدد من الشركاء ونحن نرى
ان هذا الامر
وانخرطه بصوره جده مع مجموعه كبيره من
الاقتصادات منها الولايات المتحده التي
تعدد استراتيجيا شركه استراتيجيا ومستمرون
في حوارنا معها
في مجالات تتعلق بالامن
والجون السياسيه
وكذلك في مجال الاقتصادي الذي يوجد مجموعه
كبيره من البرامج التي نعمل بها مع الصين
نعمل بحث عن الولايات المتحده اما الصين
فهي ثاني اكبر اقساط في العالم فان سوف
نستمر في خططنا
المستمره من اجل تنويع الاقتصاد بعيدا عن
النفط ومن اجل بنائه
اكثر قوه
تقتصر على طرف واحد بل العمل على بناء
اقتصاد مستدام في بيئه متكامله اذا اننا
منخرطون مع كافه العربيه
بعد نجاح الوساطه السعوديه الاماراتيه
الاخيره في تبادل الامريكي الروسي
هل من الممكن ان نشهد همم وساطه اخرى
السعوديه صينيه او خليجيه صينيه خاصه
باوكرانيا وروسيا لوقف الحرب
الحقيقه السعوديه منفتح على كل جهود
الوساطه بالتاكيد لكن لم يبحث شيء من هذا
صحيفه بيبلز داي
و
الدول العربيه في مجال الفضاء
احتمالات التعاون في مجال التكنولوجيا بين
الصين والدول العربيه شكرا شكرا
جزيلا مع ان سؤال لك حول الدول العربيه
فوق سوف احيله الكلمات الى امين عام جامعه
الدول العربيه
اعتقدوا
في الوثيقه
المشار اليها
والتي تحمل عنوان التعاون التقنيه
همم
اجزاء الخطه
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتعاون في هذا القطاع الفضائيه
سند واتساب
كامله لماذا لانها تحتوي
على المواد
جامعه الدول العربيه والصين
للتعامل معها
مايكل
انا
صحفيه من جلوبال تايم
ما هو الدور الذي تضعه السعوديه في
سياستها الخارجيه اجزاء الصين وما هو
توقعاتكم بالنسبه لطبيعه العلاقات
المستقبليه مع الصين بان هذه العلاقات قد
تكون نموذج بالنسبه لبقيه الدول العربيه
اشركائنا في الصين التي نراها من متقاربه
في كافه القضايا
سواء في طبيعه همم العلاقات المتعدده
الاطراف سوف نستمر في العلاقه في التعامل
بصوره اللاصقه ليس فقط لخدمه مصلحه البلاد
فحسب من اجل خدمه السلام والتعاون في
العالم
اما بالنسبه لدول العربيه فلا استطيع
التحدث نيابه عنها لكن كما راينا اليوم من
خلال القمه والخطابات التي ادلت هناك
اهتمام واضح وقوي في بناء طبيعه علاقات
متينه مع الصين من قبل كافه الدول العربيه
مساء الخير رنين قناه ال بي سي اي لبنان
ثلاث اسئله سريعين جدا بدايه هل ستلعب
الصين اي دور على خط العلاقات
بين عدد من الدول العربيه وايران السؤال
الثاني اعود الى موضوع العلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل لو كان
الجمهوريون في السلطه اليوم هل كانت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لتزخم العلاقه مع الصين الى هذا المستوى
وجمع كل الدول العربيه في الرياض للقاء مع
الصين والسؤال الثالث يتعلق ببلدي لبنان
لاحظنا بانه بمختلف البيانات التي صدرت
عنكم في مختلف اللقاءات سواء كانت ثنائيه
ام غير ثنائيه كان هناك ذكر له لبنان ادرك
بانه كان هناك ذكر لعدد اخر من الدول ولكن
في ظل كل ما يحكى عن عدم اهتمام المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بلبنان هل من رساله
معينه عبر ذكر لبنان في كل هذه اللقاءات
شكرا
شكرا بس مش كان السؤال الاول عفوا
والثاني
بالنسبه نعرف ان الصين حريصه جدا على امن
واستقرار المنطقه
كما نحن حريصين جدا على الامن والاستقرار
المنطقه كما كافه الدول الخليج حريصه على
امن واستقرار المنطقه كما كافه الدول
العربيه حريصه على امن واستقرار المنطقه
وجزء من امن واستقرار المنطقه لا شك هو
الوصول الى علاقه ايجابيه بين دول المنطقه
وبين ايران لانها هي في النهايه جزء من
المنطقه ولا مجالها استقرار المنطقه الا
بعلاقه جيده بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والخليج ودول المنطقه الاخرى
وجارتنا ايران وسوف نستمر في السعي الى
ذلك سوف نستمر في مد اليد همم الى جيراننا
جيران لايجاد سبيل لهذه العلاقه الايجابيه
همم ونسمع من وقت الى اخر تصريحات
الايجابيه منهم نتمنى ان نستطيع ان
نترجمها ان شاء الله جميعا همم الى علاقه
حقيقيه ايجابيه تخدم ليس فقط استقرار
المنطقه لكن تخدم رفاه شعوبنا جميعا همم
سواء ان شعوب المملكه او الشعب الايراني
وهذا متاح لكن يتطلب همم ايجابيه وجديه
وجميع الاطراف همم ونرحب بكافه الاطراف
التي قد تسعى ل- اا لتسخير الاجواء
المناسبه لذلك بالنسبه للسؤال الثاني
حقيقه همم اولا همم
التعاون الصيني والعربي ليس وليد لحظه نعم
سوف اسمح لمعاليه ان يضيف لكن هو ليس وليد
لحظه هو شيء بني عبره سنين همم تتوج الان
بالقمه الاولى هذه همم وسيدكرون الامين
متى تكررت هذا القمه لكنها منذ فتره همم
بالنسبه لنا همم كما ذكرت الشراكه مع
الصين لها اهميه واهميه تاتي في المقام
الاول انها الصين بالنسبه للموقع العمله
السعوديه اولا ولكن اعتقد اغلب الدول
العربيه لما يكون هي الشركه التجاري الاول
همم وبذلك بناء علاقه قويه وبناء
نسيج من المنافع المشتركه لابد ان يكون
بالنسبه لنا اولويه قسوه ولا يعني المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وحسب ما اعلم كل الدول
العربيه لا تبع سياساتها بناء على مصالح
الاخرين تضع سياساتها بناءا على مصالحها
هي هي وسوف نتابع مصالحنا وسوف همم نصيغ
نستمر بناء على تلك المصالح بغض النظر عن
وجهات النظر وسوف نبقى في نفس الوقت الحين
الحوار مع جميع الشركائنا همم غربا وشرقا
لضمان ان يكون هناك همم تفهم كامل لما
نقوم به وان يكون هناك همم سعيد لتحقيق
ايضا هذه المنافع المشترك المنافع
المشتركه ليست فقط
نحن نسعى خلف مصالحنا ومصالحنا نجدها في
الغرب ونجدها في الشرق واينما وجدناها سوف
شكرا سمو الامير
يعني لا يجب انه نتصور انه السياسات
العربيه او المواقف العربيه او الزخم اللي
احنا بنشربه في هذه اللحظه انه وليد الشهر
الماضي
المنتدى
اطلق في 2004
فكريته اتحطت من 2001
فيما يتعلق بهذه القمه تحديدا
فكرتها انبثقت في 2019
وكانت في 2019
على ما اعتقد اداره جمهوريه مش مش لان
الاداره الديمقراطيه جاءت في 2020 في
2019 في حديث بيني انا شخصيا في بيجين مع
وزير خارجيه الصين قلت له ايه رايك لو
نرفع هذا المنتدى قال لي والله اللي في
ايدل الوزراء العرب فلما رجعنا اشتغلنا
على هذا الموضوع وتقرر في 2020 بمعنى احنا
كنا عارفين انه هناك دعوه همم سعوديه همم
عمل هذا المنتدى من 2020 جاء الكفت علينا
كوفي 19 عطل ال- ال- العمليه ل همم سنوات
همم وبالتالي لا يجب انه تطرح اسئله او
همم او يتصور البعض انه اصله هذا رد فعل
على همم حدث او فعل او اجراء تم في شهر
يوليو الماضي او في شهر همم يناير 21 قصه
من 2019 ومن 2004 ومن 2002 شكرا
قناه العربيه
الان همم
ظرف اختيار رئاسهتين ونتمنى ان يوفقون في
اختيار همم
يقود هذا البلد الى بر الامان والى مسار
التنميه
حقيقيه والى مسار ايضا استقلاليه حقيقيه
هذا ابنه
هذا واضح واضح سبور الامير انه ال ال
مدير المركز بيقول لنا خلاص خلاص روحوا
نعم
ما عندي جواب ما عندي شيء اضيفه على هذا
حقيقه نحن مهتمون فقط بمراقبه الوضع
وتمنياتنا للبنانيين ان يختاروا
مسارهم فيما يحقق رخائهم واستقرارهم
واستقلاله وعزتهم وين نختاره هذا المسار
يجرون ليس فقط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
معهم لكن كافه الدول العربيه معهم باذن
الله همم واذا تتحملون هل تطفئه
طيب قناه العربيه في المنتصف
احمد قناه العربيه سؤال معالي الامين
العام جميع دول عربيه ومعالي وزير
الخارجيه هناك كان هناك اتفاق وتوافق
اقتصادي وتجاري هل هذا انعكاس هذا التوافق
والاتفاق سياسيا في القمه الصينيه العربيه
حول ايران وتدخلها في شؤون بعض الدول
العربيه يعني نحن نتحدث عن توافق فعلي ليس
يتوافق البعض يذكر انه يكتب في البيانات
توفق فعل كان هناك توافق فعلي ام لا
السؤال الثاني همم لماذا همم يعني عندما
تكون او يكون هناك تقارب سعودي او خليجي
ليس فقط مع الصين او حتى مع روسيا يتحدث
البعض عن رسائل مبطنه توجه الولايات
المتحده من وجهه نظريكم لماذا دائما يحدث
هذا الامر همم
تتحدثون ان هذا الامر هو امر طبيعي
واستراتيجي لكن لماذا دائما ليس فقط تغرب
معصين حتى التقارب مع خطاب اخرى كروسيا او
غيرها يتم الحديث عن رسائل مبطلات وجه
الولايات المتحده شكرا
يعني هو ببساطه شديده ببساطه شديده
استمعنا للكثير من الرؤساء العرب يتحدث عن
عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه من قبل
القوى الخارجيه وعلى الجانب الاخر شفنا
الرئيس
لا توافق الصين على التدخلات في شؤون
الدول ولكن تحديدا على دوله ما هذا
الموضوع غير مطروح لانه همم نحن نتفهم
اعتبارات تقود الصين في مواقف وهم يتفهمون
اعتبارات تقود الدول العربيه في مواقف
يعني في كلمتي انا شخصيا النهارده تحدثت
على
منع الانتشار النووي لانه هناك طرف اقليمي
يسعى لبناء قدره نوويه هناك شقوق حول
مدى ااا هل هي سلميه ولا اا عسكريه ولكن
هناك ايضا
بالتاكيد قوه نوويه مؤكده موجوده على
الارض اسمها اسرائيل
يعني بتبحث المسائل في
المبادئ العامه بتاعتها
يعني كل اللي يستطيع اقوله على هذا
السعوديه سياستنا الخارجيه مبنيه على اساس
مهم وهو كيف ندعم مسار التنميه
وهذا هو الاساس التي نعمل عليه وهو الاساس
الذي وجهتنا فيه القياده انه السياسه
الخارجيه مسخنه دعم مسار التنميه لحمايه
مكتسباتنا الوطنيه وحمايه امن الوطن ودعم
مشاريعنا التنمويه ودعم همم ما تسعى عليه
القياده من خلال رؤيه 20 30 والبرامج
الاخرى في تحقيق رفاه مستدام للشعب
السعودي وسوف نستمر في هذا المنوال كيف
يحلل الاخرون فهذا اترك لهم
نعطيك قناه المصريه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نشات اديهي قناه
المصريه
معالي الامين العام ربما كان السؤال
الاكثر ترتيبا في القاعه هو هل هناك
استداره عربيه نحو الشرق او نحو الجنوب
وهل هذه الاستداره استداره فرضتها الظروف
والطائرات السياسيه الموجوده في العالم
واعاده تمركز القوى الكبرى ام انها اعاده
هندسه علاقات وفقا لمصالح الدول العربيه
ده السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني تحدثت
معاليكم عن الامن الماء العربي كان متضمن
داخل الوثيقه وايضا النهارده كان في دعوه
من الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي الرئيس
المصري الى المنتدى انه يضع على جدول
الاولوياته الامن المائي العربي وايضا كان
في دعوه الى الجانب اليوتيوب لتفعيل هذه
المباحثات ليه مصالح جميع الشعوب يعني
ماذا يمكن ان يعني تعالوا المنتدى والدول
العربيه همم جميعا في الحفاظ على الامن
الماء العربي اا اسف جدا سؤال باشغلني
شخصيا من العامل الماضي همم وهو همم يعني
كل ما نفعله الان ترميم
كيف يمكن الحفاظ على الدوله الوطنيه
لورا محترم
ههه
انا بابتسم الحياه او بضحك
لحديثك على ما يسمى بالربيع العربي اللي
انا مطلق عليه من وقته في 2011 ولا علي
كتل الوحيد ويمكن احمد موسى كمان
كان اسمه في رايي دائما التدمير العربي
تدمير العربي حصل وخلاص لكن الدوله
الوطنيه
وفي دول مازال هناك جهد
نتكلم في موضوع
[موسيقى]
السياسي
وهل هناك اتجاه نحو الشرق او غيره يعني
اكون امين وصريح جدا معك
منذ الثمانينات ونحن نشهد
قوه اقتصاديه تكنولوجيه نائمه في اسيا وفي
المحيط الهادي
وكلنا نتذكر القصه بتاعت النمور الاربعه
وبيتكلموا كانوا على نمور الاربعه
سنغافوره وماليزيا وتايوان
ابتداء من سنه 79 او 80 لما تمكن من
السلطه وانطلق في بناء الصين الحديثه
وشفنا الصين الحديثه بتابجو بقوه اقتصاديه
هائله
وشوفنا العالم الغربي وهو يتحدث على
انتقال مركز الثقل الاقتصادي الى
الشرق دي كلها معلومات كلنا عارفينها طيب
العرب اللي عاوزين يبنوا مجتمعاتهم
وابنه قدرتهم على
توفير الرفاها لشعوبهم
فهم كمان لهم القدره انهم يشوفوا وبالتالي
يتجهم شرقا في انطلاقه نحو التعاون
الاقتصادي والتكنولوجي مع هذه القوه
الصاعده ده شق شق الاخر
لا احد يزعم ولا ينبغي ان احد يزعم على
الاقل من وجهه نظري انه
انسوا الولايات المتحده وانسوا العالم
الغربي لانهم قوه
واحده فيهم اكبر قوه اقتصاديه في العالم
واكبر قوه عسكريه في العالم
وميزانتها ميزاناتها 730 مليار دولار في
السنه
بيساوي
التسعه او ال 10 التاليين لها في الانفاق
العسكري وبالتالي
ما حدش بيتحول ولا حد بيلعب سياسات همم
موازين القوه وما فيش حرب بارده بعد يعني
ربما نشات حرب بارده وربما
تقول لي طيب وليه مش هتشهدها اقول لك لانه
في لعل هناك ضمان صمام امن في العالم ايه
هو صمام الامن في العالم انه حجم التجاره
الامريكيه
الصينيه في اللحظه اللي انا بتكلم فيها
معك دي 600 او 700 مليار دولار في السنه
الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده في السبعينات
والثمانينات كانت لا تتجاوز حجم التجاره
عده مليارات وبالتالي احتمالات الصدام
كانت موجوده وما حصلتش فليه تحصل النهارده
ما حدش هيشتغل على موازين القوه او الحرب
البارده او علاقات بين الاطراف ما يحدث
الان مع الصين هو اعتراف بقوه اقتصاديه
تكنولوجيه ن- ناميه ولها قدراتها ولها
منطلقاتها والعرب يرغبون في بناء همم
مجتمعاتهم
والاستفاده من هذا خصوصا انه لما بيقدم لك
هذا ما بيقدمه لكش بشروط بيقدمه بدون شروط
ما بيقولكش والله اصلك انت عندك كذا ولا
كذا ولا كذا ولا كذا
وكذا دي في بطن الشاعر
الامن المائي الدول العربيه واقفه مع
السودان ومصر وهناك قرارات صادره من
الجامعه العربيه ومن المجلس الوزاري بتقول
ان احنا بنطالب
تسويه ملزمه او اتفاق ملزم بنؤيد المطلب
السوداني وابنؤيد المطلب المصري
وبنطالب اثيوبيا بانها تتفاوض
يعني بحسن
»
ونعمل ان ان نحقق هذا في ما يتعلق
بالاعلان اللي صادر بين العرب والصين في
نفس المعنى بمعنى انه الامن المائي للدول
شئ اساسي كوب 8 27 كشف هذا جدا المساله مش
بس الامن الغذائي ولكن ايضا الامن المائي
لانه ما فيش غذاء بدون مايه شكرا
اعتقالات الجزيره
بدر باقات الجزيره سوالي موجه لسمو الامير
فيصل فرحان سمو الامير هل تم التباحث مع
الجانب الصيني بخصوص ملفات التسليح
والانظمه الدفاع في القمم الثلاثه التي
عقدت في الرياض
لما يكون هذا مجال النقاش لان القمم اللي
عقدت هي قمم تركز على مجالات اقتصاديه
وتنمويه وكان هذا محور الاساسي للنقاش
ويعني المخرجاتها على كل حال معلنه
بالكامل يعني سواء ان اكمس الصينيه
السعوديه والصينيه همم الخليجيه او
الصينيه العربيه والتربيه الحقيقيه همم
العلاقه مع الصين اعمق بكثير من هذه
الاعتبارات العلاقه مع الصين كما ذكرت
سابقا يعني الاقتصاد الثاني في العالم
وكما شرحها ما عليه همم يعني الانخراط في
شراكه استراتيجيه اقتصاديه تجاريه مع
الصين محوريه اعتقد كل الدول ونعمل من
خلال هذه راك تعزيز مسار التنميه في
العالم العربي والعنوان الاساس همم عندنا
لهذه القمم هو التعاون والتنميه واختير
هذا بعنايه لم يكن همم يعني اختيارا همم
عبثيا كان له دلالات
ونستمر في بناء هذه العلاقه مع الصين ومع
شركاء على الاخرين
همم السؤال همم الزملاء الشرق الاوسط
السلام عليكم
سؤالي الى سمو وزير الخارجيه السعودي همم
اليوم كان همم اول لقاء على مستوى القمه
خليجي همم صيني وعربي صيني همم هناك شراكه
همم اقتصاديه همم عاليه المستوى جدا بين
الدول العربيه والصين هل يمكن ان يبنى على
لقاءات القمه التي عقدت اليوم في الرياض
بحيث تصبح شراكه السياسيه بين الدول
العربيه وتحديدا الدول الخليجيه بنفس
المستوى للشراكه الاقتصاديه المرتفعه من
الاساس شكرا الدول العربيه
يعني الشراكه السياسيه بين الدول الخليديه
والعربيه هذه قائمه موجوده وهي اساس من
العمل العربي المشترك
يعني كما ذكر سابقا بالنسبه لنا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كثير من الدول
العربيه ااه التنميه هو الدافع التنميه هو
الدافع ليس فقط لعقد هذه القمه لكن هو ما
همم همم
يستقي منه سياسات الى الخارجيه والعمل
السياسي همم ان لم يخدم مصالحك الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه ويعز ظرفاء شهبك
فحقيقه هذا الماضي يعني موارد كثيره ولذلك
نعمل على هذا المجال وهذا يعني ان لا شك
ان هناك انخراط سياسي مع الصين كما ان
هناك
سياسي لموقع السعوديه مع جميع الاطراف
فاعل على الساحه السياسيه ولها دور مهم
همم ليس فقط في المنطقه لكن ابعد منها
ولكن نحن نركز في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تسخيره هذا الدور السياسي لخدمه
مصالحنا ومصالحنا التنمويه اولا بما فيه
حمايه امننا همم من اجل حمايه مسار
التنميه هذا لكن ايضا لحمايه امن واستقرار
المنطقه وتسخير سبل همم تعزيز همم
النمو الاقتصادي همم بين همم الدول
المنطقه
شكرا لكم اصحاب السبول المعالي والشكر لكم
على حضوركم شكرا لكم ويعطيكم العافيه
ونعتذر عن اللي ما قدرنا ناخذ شكرا
[تصفيق]